In this final video, we'll review some future considerations for our FBX Data Ingestion Pipeline.
Unreal Engine now has a series of plugins referred to as Interchange.
What are these? Well, they're a new import and export framework,
they're format-abnostic, they're asynchronous, customizable, they can work at runtime,
and they like some formats better than others.
For example, they work very well with GLTF and OBJ formats, as well as textures.
They can be a little bit more finicky with FBX, but it's certainly worth playing with.
This seems to be the future of how Unreal Engine would like to process various data
that doesn't go as well through the Datasmith Pipeline, so give this a try if you haven't already.
To take a brief look at the interchange system, we can see a number of plugins available to us,
including OpenUSD, and you'll see that if we navigate further up from our Uproject folder,
we have an Assets folder with a number of different geometry types available to us.
Gaunt is our skeletal mesh, we have some 3ds Max textures, and let's try importing a GLTF file.
So this will come in via that new interchange format with a number of different options,
and this is how we see Unreal Engine beginning to coalesce how it imports different kinds of data.
Data mesh is...
Ah, and if I wanted that all to be one object, I could try that again.
I could find the checkbox for Combined,
and then we can find the Combined one here,
and that's an import using the new interchange system.
Let's try the same thing with an FBX file,
and we can see the same thing here, interchange generic Assets Pipeline.
We also have some presets, Assets Materials Textures, but whether it's an FBX file, a GLTF, an OBJ, etc.,
this is what we're seeing the future of Unreal Engine imports look like when they're not Datasmith,
a fairly unified list of options using this new interchange system.
And we can see by default our lion here came in with Nanite enabled, perhaps at the wrong scale.
If we wanted to fix the units, we could go reimport mesh with Dialog, type Unit, and we can see it's in meters,
so the offset uniform scale, if we want to go from meters to centimeters, can simply be 0.01.
And just noting that if we have Nanite enabled but we're packaging to a platform that does not support Nanite,
Nanite will actually automatically generate a fallback proxy mesh, and you should still have a working project,
just with slightly less control over how it gets reduced.
I hope you've enjoyed and found something useful about this course on Static Mesh Data Ingestion for FBX.
My name is Alex Coulomb, and I wish you luck on your Unreal Engine journey.
Bye for now.